hello everyone thanks so much for coming
this is f sharp little F sharp for C
sharp programmers my name is convolution
I have a website F sharp F a non-profit
comm which I think kind of gives away my
bias so I'm a big fan of f sharp and I
will try not to be too biased I'll try
and present why I think this is an
interesting language for you to learn
but if I if I go overboard like you
don't have to trust me
you know you can look for yourself so
the goal of this talk really it's just a
demystify F sharp a bit a lot of people
think that functional programming is
very scary and there's monads and weird
mathematical things I'm just going to
try and demystify a little bit just so
that you can kind of maybe get
interested in investigating it obviously
you can't become an expert in an hour so
and I'm not going to go through this is
not going to be one of those feature
things where I show you all the features
of the language because I think that's
the kind of stuff you can learn by
yourself I'm going to talk about more
like the philosophy of language and how
functional programming is different from
audiology programming and how F sharp
has a different philosophy than C sharp
in terms of how you do things so is it
worth the efforts to learn another new
language like there's all these new
languages there's rust and there's go
and I was caught learn and it's like you
know is it really worth it to learn a
new language so this is a quote that I
like a language it doesn't affect the
way you think about programming is not
worth knowing so for example if you know
c-sharp learning Java is not going to
change the way you think about
programming so it's not worth learning
Java I mean might be worth learning Java
to get a job but it's not worth learning
it to try and expand your minds like on
the head I think F sharp is a language
that will change the way you think about
programming and so I do think it's worth
putting effort in to learn it here was a
conversation I saw on reddit I think
some said well your f sharp is a little
bit better but is it really worth the
effort you know which I sympathize with
that means look there's so many new
things you really don't want to spend
lot
I'm learning something you know if
you're not going to really get anything
after but something with respondents
with this you know learning a sharp was
a big boost to my career as a c-sharp
developer so it's person it doesn't
either professionally there aren't that
many f-sharp jobs but we're talking
about personal development here were
talking about learning new paradigms
learning the ways of programming and he
said this knowledge actually made me a
better program in general so that's a
good reason to learn f-sharp
another way to before you put a lot of
effort into something is to find
somebody who has done it before so find
someone you trust who has learned
c-sharp and has also learned a sharp and
ask them is it worth learning and if
they say yes you know don't have to
trust me but you know don't trust people
who've never nobody just look at it and
say it's horrible don't bother because
you need to have it you need to have
experience on both sides and only then
can you make it a sensible decision so
find someone like that and ask them what
they think all right so some
misconceptions about f-sharp I'll just
clear out quickly it's developed by
Microsoft Research not Microsoft proper
but it became a proper maxilla product
in 2010 shape with Visual Studio and now
it's on a parity with c-sharp and VB and
so on parity in in quotes it's open
source I think it's one of the first
microprocessors it's on github you can
change the compiler and put a pull
request in and go for it it's
cross-platform it works on Linux it
works on Windows on Mac it works with
you know dotnet core it works with mono
obviously it works really well in Visual
Studio but it also works really well
with other editors of Visual Studio
codes has a fantastic they're sharp
plug-in called
ionize which I highly recommend and
there's also things that you imagine
them and so on really important accident
friendly community when you're learning
a language you don't want people to you
know tell you asking stupid questions
when you're beginning right you want
people who are supportive so if you go
to FL Paul which is the desktop software
foundation there's instructions on how
to download there's also instructions on
how to get to the f-sharp slack channel
which way there's a beginner's channel
in there you can ask questions and on
f-sharp on Twitter
hashtag that's a great place to ask
questions or to find out what's going on
at their shop right so what am I going
to talk about so the first thing when
talked about is the differences between
C sharp and F sharp when you're learning
a new language you always want to kind
of compare it with what you already know
and that's true for anything I actually
think that's a bad idea clear honest I
think when you're learning something new
especially if it's completely different
paradigm you should actually have a like
a beginner's mind and forget everything
you know because it's going to interfere
with your learning so ideally when
you're learning language like F sharp
you should forget everything you know as
usual that's kind of impossible but
that's would be the recommended approach
because otherwise you're going to get
frustrated and say well why doesn't it
do this and why doesn't it do that but
since you're here I am and since you are
C sharp people I'm going to talk about
the differences anyway so the first
thing is the syntax is very different
and this is probably what you see first
and so what puts a lot of people off and
I'll talk about that type inference is
something which is very different
between F sharp and C sharp to default
the difference so in F sharp everything
defaults to immutability for example and
mutabilis is something special and it's
a different philosophy about what's
important when you program and then I'll
talk about things which is sort of
special to F sharp that C sharp doesn't
have the fact that F is a functional
first language the fact that F sharp has
an algebraic type system and the fact
that they're sharp is an interactive
language you can play with it like
Python or Ruby it feels like a scripting
language these differences between
c-sharp by the way I've ranked them from
the least important and most important
people really focus on the syntax that
is the least important thing about
language the fact that's got a different
philosophy I think is more important and
that but it's not obvious just by
looking at the code is not obvious that
they have a difficulty but I'll talk
about that so let's start with a syntax
because everyone this is things that
people really complain about so what I'm
going to do is I'll start off with a
c-sharp example and I'll mutate it so
I'll transform it into extra-large code
so here's a mutable class and C shop
it's got it's a person class it's got a
name property and a birthday for
pretty damn close really all right so
the first thing first difference in
syntax is indentation rather than curly
braces and you've probably seen this
here's all the curly braces and the
question is do we really need them to
the add value right if you look at the
see shop codes I think one third of C
shop code is curly braces is it really
that important the indentation always
already gives you everything you need to
know so this is the codes with curly
braces and this is the code without
curly braces with indentation okay
there's the curly braces there's the
code of indentation now some people will
say well you know is it really that
harder to read without the 30 bases some
people say yes it's like oh no this is
like impossible to read I can't possibly
understand this code I merely that's a
silly thing to say okay so if you if you
a couple things notice first of all you
might have noticed I put equal signs
that's used to start the blocks whoops
and the other thing is that we can shift
all the without the curly braces we
actually get a vertical space back so we
get a lot of vertical space compaction
which is much nice which is very nice so
if you're worried about white space here
is a helpful Venn diagram there are
people who complain about white space
and there are people who've used the
language with white space and the
intersection is a very small
intersection there there are some people
who do complain and have you know who
have used it but normally people who
complained actually haven't done it so
people complain about Python believing
actually inspiring okay
here's a claimant who is you know that
can't get much more hacker credentials
and that he said Python so he's talking
about Python which is very similar to F
sharp in terms of the white space the
pythons using white space stopped
feeling unnatural after about 20 minutes
I just indented code like I would with C
and it works all right and that's pretty
much it just indented the way you would
normally do and pretty much things work
that is not the hardest part about
learning a shot believe me so you know
give it a go don't let this white space
thing bother you how many people here
know Python
okay well then you've got no problem
problem specials right okay here's some
other syntax differences I'll just go
through quickly a lot of these things
are also going to be available in C at
some point if they're not available now
I'm sort of losing track of which
features are actually making it into the
C releases with first one backing fields
for constructor parameters if you look
at the constructor there's a name and a
birthday and then there's a backing
fields which will name a birthday and
it's just a lot of names and that is
like duplicate stuff everywhere right
that's annoying let's get rid of it
so in F sharp the parameters that you
passed the constructor automatically
become backing fields so you don't need
to define them and then you can just in
your property you can just return it
that's saves a bit of code right there I
think that's very nice
the primary constructor and the class
definition get merged so in c-sharp the
Constructors are separate kind of
methods as it were separate from the
class definition in F sharp you take
this constructor and you put it at the
top because how often do you have more
than one constructor I mean sometimes
you do and in F sharp you can have
secondary concerns too that's not
problem but almost always why not just
like make it part of the last definition
like that that saves a bit of or it also
saves it over to the space that's
another three or four lines we've saved
right there there's noise okay so this
is an immutable class we've got all
these gets everywhere get-get-get let's
get rid of the gets okay the gets are
gone that's good
another thing we don't need is
semicolons nobody likes semicolons right
everybody hates semicolons just get rid
of them now occasionally you do have two
things on the same line and you can use
a semicolon if you need to but you don't
need to normally okay no return so in
c-sharp you have a return keyword to
tell you this is the return of the
method whatever in F sharp you don't
need it and code looks like this and the
reason is that F sharp is an expression
oriented language everything is an
expression not a statement so an
expression is something that returns
something it's not just it doesn't just
do something always return something's
like if
initiatives doing an action and a funk
right everything's a funk in a pair shut
there's no actions it always returns
something and so it always attend
something you always gonna need a return
statement so you just make the last line
of the block be the return so in this
case the name is the last line that's
what gets returns all right so you get
implicit returns it's very nice all
right public members okay so this is a
mutable class people can't change it
why make everything project so in is
again it's noise like in c-sharp you
spend a lot of time typing public like
let's not get rid of it let's get rid of
public we don't need product now an
f-sharp this is a good example where the
defaults are different in F sharp you
can make things private if you want to
even write the same havoc same
accessibility modifies you can say
private and internal and also the
defaults are different the thought is
public in seashell the default it's
private
all right type inference okay so in the
constructor we say that the name is a
string and the birthdays of dates and in
the properties we say the name is a
string in the birthdays a date it's like
why are we duplicated this why can't the
compiler figure this out why do I have
to keep typing date time over over write
in F sharp the compiler does forget out
for us right we specify it once and then
go after it's figured it out now at this
point our properties are kind of getting
kind of hard to know the publicist
written too sparse so in F sharp you
have to say that something is actually a
member so that's a little bit of a
clunky thing you have to say this is a
member remember this dot so this is the
self is the same as distance to Shabbos
the self reference okay and so that in
place of class remember and use the same
syntax for methods there's property so
this is a methods age and you calculate
the age by doing something and again I
don't have to return I just say that the
difference mine divided by 3 6 5 that's
the age so methods and properties look
very similar in a shop now notice that
with age I didn't have to say return to
names right into the compiler forget it
up
so let's type annotations so in c-sharp
types come before variable name it's a
date time birthday string name in F
sharp is give around the types come
afterwards so it's birthday : day time
name : stream if you've ever used pipe
scripts has the same thing a lot of
languages do this most modern languages
now have adopt this kind of standard way
of doing types so the C kind of
languages have their own way of doing it
but other languages do it this way
different keywords okay now if you care
about this is the kind of syntax
difference that really if you care about
this I'm sorry you know I can't help you
different keywords so in F sharp C shall
we use class and we use var in F sharp
we use type now we use let alright and
those different keywords but really
that's all you have to remember it's not
that hard alright now Muncy sharp does
have a lot of these features when I wear
this I think I've wrote this based on I
know I haven't done C sharp for us I've
kind of lost track of what's coming but
this is an example where the constructor
is merged with the class definition
it's got alter properties it's got
expression bodied members and so on so
it does kind of look like c-sharp except
for the fact you've got public and
you've got the duplicated types and
everything and the expression body
members only work for single lines and
this you know but it's the same idea I
mean you know conciseness is good
because tightness is really nice if you
can through it alright now that was the
object-oriented syntax I showed you the
functional programming syntax is even
simpler because all this member stuff
that's kind of ugly so in front of the
programming the key thing is you
separate the data structures from the
behavior so the functions that act on
the data are separate from the data
things themselves so in F sharp if I
want to define a person I would define
it like this so this is what we call a
record type in F sharp and it kind of
looks a little bit like JSON I suppose
there's a name as a birthday and that's
the type this is an immutable data
structure with two properties there is
no behavior it's just like you could
think of it as
a dto as well it's like a dumb object
with no behavior if I want some
functions that work in it i define
separately i define an age function and
the age function looks like that so
again it's let there is one parameter
which is person and there's a space
between the parameters and that becomes
important later on when you do things
like partial application so in front of
languages you can use spaces between the
functional parameters notice that I
didn't have to what else are they yeah I
didn't have any type annotations but the
fact that by passing that person then
the person has a birthday it figures out
that the person is a person type and it
figures out there's an int return so if
I look at the the woods infer the type
influence we'll say this is a person -
int function I don't have to specify
that which is very nice so there you go
that's type inference is great and so it
kind of looks like if you use the Python
this looks very much like Python you're
not specifying any types anywhere just
kind of writing code and you know but
unlike pythons are strictly type so
you'll get a compile error if you make
mistake so as I said syntax is not the
most important thing it's never the most
important thing about a program language
but okay I'm going to make an exception
originally we had like 20 line throwing
on lines of code now we've got five
lines of code if we take those two
properties and we're fine if you compare
C sharp and F sharp code bases at words
that actually pretty much the same code
when we win we'll find that F sharp code
in general is about three times less you
know one third of my check shell code C
shell code because of the vertical
compression because the letter braces
the lack of null checking the fact they
don't have constructors and stuff
there's just a lot less codes and that's
kind of I think that's kind of important
in those syntax is not that important I
think the fact you can see three times
more on your screen it's like getting a
super large monitor so that's nice
and you don't have to write 1/3 as much
code that's nice too so that's not like
I say syntax is not that form but I
think concise
is important and I think c-sharp and
sometimes be a little verbose you know
but that's not the I mean I wouldn't say
that's not the only reason to using
language so just let you know as I've
been more important reasons type
inference okay so that's the syntax
stuff type inference here's a function
do something and it's got some
parameters and F N and X and let's say
we're going to add one to X and we're
going to pass it into this F so f is
obviously some sort of function and then
the output of that function is a Y and
then we're going to take Y we're going
to add it to hello so what can I haven't
specified anything in the parameters
right so can the compiler figure out
what's going on and the answer is yes it
does and the way it does it like this
first of all it says that X has to be an
int because anything you add an int has
to be then F shops really strict there's
no kind of coercion between types so you
can't add a float to an int and you
can't add an n64 to the Infinity they're
all different
so this knows that X has to be an int
and then it also knows because you're
passing into FS memory function now what
about Y Y has to be a string for the
same reason if you want to add something
to another string Y has to be a string
so now if we look at F we know the input
F is an int and the output of F is a
string so it's an interesting function
and so finally this is the inferred type
okay the first parameter F is a function
which takes the internet registry the
second parameter is an integer and the
return type the very last line is a
string because that's hello positive so
the type emphases works like this it
continued quite a lot of stuff
occasionally you need to annotate types
but many many cases you can just write
code like this and it just works because
that's all very good but is it really
how useful that really I mean it's kind
of save some typing let me show you a
more complex example okay this is the
group by extension method from the link
and I challenge you to scan this and
figure out what exactly it does
there's a lot of noise here sometimes
you can't even find the name of the
method because it's buried under Wooster
I mean this is nice Dino it's nice to
know but there's a lot of noise and if
you're writing your own functions you're
gonna have to figure out what all these
types are yourself and annotate them
properly in F sharp the code looks like
this okay almost always the compiler
will figure out all this stuff for you
which is kind of cool so the benefit of
type inference is obviously less typing
but more importantly less noise you can
really focus on the logic of the code
and not worry about the kind of types
getting away again if anyone who's used
a dynamic language like Python or Ruby
you don't really need to see all the
types every single time in visual studio
and in vs code you can actually hover
over the thing that will tell you what
the types are and there's a code lens
thing I mean there's lots of things that
will tell you what the types are without
having to type them explicitly alright
different defaults so the different
defaults in F sharp it's readable by
default
mutability is a special case everything
is non null by default and if you want
null ability that's a special case
everything the F sharp record types and
stuff are structural yet structural
equality by default and reference
equality is a special case or the
classes and stuff you get reference
equality so structural quality means
that if all the properties are the same
then the two things are the same
I'm sure you've written you know in
equals and get hash codes to do that a
million times right and then everything
must be initialized that's a big
difference so let's start with
immutability so there's a value in F
sharp x equals one now in F sharp the
assignment operator is not equals the
assignment operators the backwards error
like that it's a different thing
altogether so you can't assignment an
equality or not going to get mixed up so
we're going to assign two to X and if we
try and do it the compiler is going to
complain it says it's not me at all okay
now if I do want a mutable value I have
to use the mutable keyword and then when
I assign it is happy so this is saying
that mutability something have to ask
for it's not something happens by
default
because you have to ask for it and
because it's so explicit you tend to use
it less you know it's like we tend to
vote because we're lazy right we tend to
use whatever the easiest if things in
c-sharp we've been we can create read
only class and seashell bins kind of
pain so attempts not bother so much we
everything to be rid of all you know we
tend not to do it this way in F sharp
tips that opposite everything is
immutable by default and so if you're
lazy you just follow the flow and make
everything immutable and very
occasionally you need things to be
readable
what about null ability so here's our
person type if I do this so I'm going to
say this is X is a person and I'm going
to assign it to be null I get a compile
time error person doesn't have Nile as a
value okay this is very different from C
shop where you can assign null to most
classes if I do want to assign not at
all so I have to do like this okay I
have to say allow null literal
attributes on top and I had to use a
special class and so on it's like
painful right and we need does work if I
do this but because it's much more
painful you're really never going to do
it the only reason you might want to do
is to be back fully compatible with
something you know but I never going to
use this in your code so you never going
to Mike you can pretty much rely that
all your classes in a shell are never
going to be involved that's nice when
you eliminate no checking if you have a
right defensive code in your constructor
you know if the parameter is null throw
an exception or whatever you never see
that kind of code in a shell because
nothing it's nothing so you can
guarantee that nothing's none
okay structural equality so here's our
person time again now let's say that we
have this crazy rule that if someone has
the same name and they have the same
birthday they're the same person
all right not a very good rule but I've
seen that actually done in practice so
here's a Alice version one Alice version
two both these things have the same name
they have the same birthday the question
is are they equal is alice version one
the same as alice version two and the
answer is yes in F sharp that is true
you do not have to override get hashcode
and you do not have to override
equals to get this this is the default
behavior and that's the brake relief to
me because I hate writing equals and I
always get it wrong I worry that there
might be some special case when two
things are known I haven't checked it
properly say I can never remember to do
it right I probably have bugs in my code
and the same thing with get hash code
hate writing it right so you don't have
to write that's one one big relief there
okay everything has to be initialized
okay here's our person again okay so in
c-sharp you can say here's a variable
here's a backing fielders or something
and it's just going to be a person now
in c-sharp that can be set to null the
default value for a class is not F sharp
that's Noah okay you can't there is no
default value for anything null is
certainly not a problem only fit it's
not an amiable thing so you always have
to initialize it to be something so you
never have an uninitialized variable in
Excel and if you partially initialize it
there so you set the name but you forget
to set the birthday that's also an error
every single property is required when
you initialize it so if you add a new
property all your code or break until
you fixed it which is probably good I
think I don't know you know you never
have this thing we've added a new
property in some deeper gets initializer
probably because you've got constructor
which is backwards compatible and yeah
that's never gonna happen F sharp which
it is so you can trust a lot of is to do
with trust you can trust that things
have been properly initialized so you
tend to not write defensive codes in
their shop you don't have to check for
null you don't have to check is it
initializes a valid objects all that
stuff tends to disappear so that's
another reason why the code is shorter
because there's just a lot less
defensive programming all right so
here's an is that what I think is the
most important thing which is the
different philosophy so she C sharp
obviously is derived from c-like
languages obviously it doesn't have
pointers and you know stuff like that
but it's got the imperative model you
have for loops you have mutability and
so on and so forth
f-sharp is a cousin of ML which is a
language designed in the 1970s pretty
much around the same time as C and that
M L stands for meta language and it was
originally designed to proving things
okay so it wasn't really designed to be
a kind of useful enterprise programming
language and that means there's a
different philosophy and so let's look
at example of a philosophical difference
and let's talk about predictable code so
what I mean by predictable code is can
you understand the code in front of you
just by looking at it okay you're not
allowed to look at the documentation
you're not allowed to look at rest the
code base not allowed to look at the
implementation I think just by looking
at the code in front of you can you tell
what it does right and if you can that's
great because that's one this makes
understanding the field much easier so
here's some code x equals one do
something with x and y equals hello plus
X so the question is what is y well in
c-sharp this wouldn't work but if I told
you the answer is hello world will that
give you a clue now the answers you
can't tell this is a trick question
actually because this is actually
JavaScript okay it's not sous-chef at
all this do something function in
JavaScript changes what X is from us
into a string and it does it silently so
that when I come back later and I use it
it's now a string and Y is now
HelloWorld okay this is horrible this is
horrible
this is like code you can't there's an
example of why you can't you know trust
Jessica in c-sharp that could never
happen because you got static typing you
can't change the type of something you
know magically behind the scenes so this
is an example of c-sharp being more
predictable Angelika if you look at the
seashell code you can you know the fact
they can't compile just by looking at
the code you don't have to you know look
at the implementation of do something to
figure out that it's not going to
compile
so this is good this is the kind of
thing we want so let's take this extend
this and look at some other things so
let's say we're trying to make a
predictable language rule number one
you're not allowed to change the type of
a variable once you define it that's a
very good rule okay let's look at
another example to customers and see
sharps they have the same ID in the same
name are the customers equal well you
can't tell because it depends on whether
the customer class has over equals or
not get hashcode and equals monster you
can't tell because behavior in oh in the
object-oriented world you're not
supposed to know about the behavior on
objects so they'll give something to be
opaque right so you can't tell I think
to make the code a predictable language
if they have the same values they should
be equal
okay now that I'm not saying that force
to be true but this is on this
particular set of guidelines making
things predictable it makes life much
more predictable okay here is a customer
and here is an order and they both
happen to have the same properties and
the same values in those properties so
the next question is the customer equal
to the order all right can you tell well
you might say well it depends on how
they've overridden equality and so on
it's like no that's the wrong answer
this is probably a bug like if you've
accidentally compared the two things by
mistake why would you ever compare a
customer to an order this locus of bugs
in your code you've you've typed the
wrong thing so ideally your compiler
would say you're not allowed this is a
compile error you're not allowed to
compare two different things right so
for predictability point of view that
should be compile time error okay how
about another one let's say you create a
customer then you say the customer has
an address and the address has a country
and you what is the value of that what
is the address country well what's going
to happen are you going to get a null
reference so you're going to get who
knows
maybe maybe the customers initialized
address to something valid I don't know
I can't tell all right because the
constructor has no parameters
so you know and we can probably assume
that it's probably been left it's not
but we can't tell and you know if the
customer if the dress is not required if
it's an optional thing then we should
make it a special optional type don't
just set it so none so here's another
one whoops
always initialize objects for valid
state we want the compiler to enforce
this okay that way we guarantee when we
look at an object we know that it's in a
valid state we never have to test with
us no we never have to test where the
address has been set and so on and if
it's not a valid state as a component
okay here's another one we've got a set
of we have a customer we add it to a set
and then we do something with the
customer we don't know what happened to
that customer a next question is that
customer still in the set of customers
true or false
and the answer is we don't know because
the process customer one you could have
mutated the customer and you might
change its hash code and when you look
it up again it's in a different place so
that you can try knowing okay that's the
problem with mutable stuff now if you
have something where as an immutable
customer and you do something if the
process customer changes it it's going
to have to return a new thing it's going
to be like they're an ER in your in your
face that it's returned a new changed
version of the customer and if it hasn't
changed the customer then it's not going
to turn anything but you know if it
doesn't return anything it can't
possibly acclaims the customer so
immutability is great there and in this
case the original customers never
changed so if the hash code can't have
changed is always going to be existing
an asset so you can rely the things are
going to work the immutability is very
useful in terms of knowing and trusting
that your code is not going to break you
know so here's all these things we
talked about can't change the title of
that one more so yeah objects inflation
should be immutable it makes life really
easy now these guidelines is about
immutability about predictability now
you might say well I need mutability
stuff for performance I know I'm
entering an array because I've got stuff
it's like yes the guidelines for good
performance are different from the
guidelines for predictability and they
they collide sometimes
performance is more important than
predictability sometimes critical to do
it is more important than performance
and you just have to choose but if
you're if you're going for predictable
immutability is the best thing to go for
one more so let's say we have some sort
of customer database and we're going to
get a customer using this ID okay so
what is the output what is the ID we get
return this customer type value what's
the idea of that customer well what
happens if the customer is missing okay
let's say you can't find in the database
what is that customer is the customer
meal know or is it even to throw an
exception or what I don't know can't
tell if the customers null if you're
going to use null as the dimension then
that's the rest of the code is on a
break if you're going to throw an
exception there's a permission I mean
I'm going to have to look at the
documentation or something to figure out
right what you really want to do is do
something this return something which is
the customer or the error and now you
can handle two different cases if
there's a customer there you can get it
and if it's an error there you can get
it but by making it a special type
called customer or error you've made it
explicit that this thing might work
might not work and if it doesn't work
here's the here's the you know the error
case you don't have to like figure out
the documentation of regret is it normal
non okay so these are over the rules
no missing data no nulls okay so trying
to document things using the type system
so f-sharp aims to be a particular
anguish like this you know you're not
allowed to change the type of variable
objects with the same values are equal
by default objects of different types
can't be compared obvious have to be
initialized something objects are
generally immutable missing data errors
I made explicit by using special types
if you use a null let's consider code
smell and f-sharp
if you throw exceptions for control flow
obviously sometimes you throw exceptions
which you just can't handle something
that's fine but if you're trying to
throw an exception a far not found
exception that's the control flow you
shouldn't throw exceptions for that so
in F sharp you tend not to do that
so f is not perfect obviously there's
backdoors and you can't always dress it
but you can see that the kind of
conventions lean in the certain
direction the philosophy behind what you
think is good code and bad code like in
c-sharp null is not necessarily a kernel
in F sharp is a state in a personal so
that's kind of a philosophical
difference between the two languages all
right so that's the end of the
differences now let's look at some of
the things which is kind of unique to F
sharp and the first thing but F sharp is
a functional first language now what do
I mean by that F sharp is a hybrid
language you can do our programming and
you can do functional programming but it
leans towards functional program we tend
to do the functional stuff first
that's all kind of go to if we can use
object programming in the you know if
there's a particular need for it in a
certain situation but generally prefer
to use functional programming if we can
so let me just quickly four people are
not familiar with functional programming
I'm just going to quickly give you some
things about front of the programming so
functional programming functions are the
most important things in functional
programming they're the building blocks
for everything the way that you combine
functions is composition so like Lego so
in an object-oriented language you make
classes that contain other classes and
you build bigger classes and then in a
functional program languages create
functions out of smaller functions and
you compose functions to make bigger
things that's how it works and
parameterization is really important in
front of the programming so in if you
want to share codes you know you don't
want to repeat yourself and you won't
have share code you tend to use
parameters rather than base classes
rather than using heritance or something
parameterization is that way of doing it
so in functional programming functions
are things and I think of like a little
bit of railway track with a tunnel on
top there's an input there's an output
like the inputs at Apple and the output
is a banana
so you see Apple Aero banana
so here is a in F sharp you like the
toad like this to define a normal thing
you say let x equals 1 and to define a
function say let ads because this and
that gives you a bit of railway track
notice that in F sharp we use the same
keywords less to define normal values
simple values and also to define
functions that's not a coincidence
because in F sharp functions are treated
like things okay so the difference being
a thing like an integer and a thing like
a function is not that big a difference
so it's a standalone thing a function
and because it's a thing it can be used
as inputs and outputs to other functions
so here's our where we track here's an
input and the output could be a function
for example because it's a thing or you
could have a function as the input to a
function or you could have a function
with an input now but then there's a an
extra parameter which is another
function which is that can controls how
the function works think strategy pan
for example strategy practice exactly
the same thing so this is the basic
model for how you do stuff in functional
programming and that's it really that's
pretty much all you need to know you can
see that it gets quite complicated
functions that return functions that
return functions can get quite
complicated but the concepts are
basically straightforward
so let's love the composition quickly so
composition you have two functions and
you want to glue them together an F
sharp that's the double angle bracket
and you glue them together now you get a
new function now what's interesting is
that you can't tell this new function
was built from smaller functions right
the fact that how it was built is now
hidden from you so for example whether
the banana go right in the low-level
codes you care about bananas but when
you get to the high level code bananas
aren't important so you've now
abstracted away that the bananas are
ever in thorns alright so that's how you
can't do abstraction
in F sharp let's say we have some
functions if I want to compose them I
use the double angle bracket again so
here's a new function that just the add
function glued together with a double
function and I can just call this is a
new function I can just call it let's
say five add one at six double it is
twelve sets the answer right so it's
just basically glued two little
functions together to make a bigger
function and I can do that with like
three functions same kind of thing all
right so as you can see this it's really
easy in a shot to do this like you can
see the language is designed to make
this easy let's look at it in c-sharp
see how in citizen C shop so in c-sharp
here are our functions and first of all
we don't get the type inference so we
have to define what the types of the
functions are and if you want to compose
functions together we have to have a
special extension method called compose
and that extension method is not built
into c-sharp so we have to write our own
it's not that hard to write but you know
you could write code like this but
nobody would understand it unless you
were functional programmer already if we
were you already knew functional program
this would be fine but I wouldn't like
if I was in a c-sharp codebase I
wouldn't like this kind of code because
no wonder that most of my colleagues
wouldn't be able to sell my program so
it's just not natural in c-sharp c-sharp
is not a functional first language
another thing you do an f-sharp a lot is
another kind of composition is piping so
let's say you you know you have a
function you add 1 to 5 and then you
want to double it and then you want to
square that in typical languages you
have these nested parentheses and they
get deeper and deeper and deeper and you
can lose track these nested function
calls and get quite confusing like you
lose their where's like where does it
start after kind of go down another
third of way I think about is as a
pipeline so you started with 5 and you
feed that into the add function the
output of 6 you take the 6 you feed it
into the double function you take that
and you feed into the square function so
this pipeline oriented model and I think
it's just a lot easier understand same
same concept the same end result but I
just didn't kind of conceptual when you
think about it and the F sharp you have
the same pipeline so if you use the UNIX
the
cool pipe right piping things on the
honor and the grand line same kind of
thing except of the pipe character in F
sharp here's a vertical bar with a angle
bracket so in F sharp you tend to see
the bottom kind of code rather than the
top kind of code the top kind of code is
kind of ugly the bottom kind of code is
very much more common and you can do the
same thing in C sharp define some
functions define a pipe helper function
but again I would never write code like
this in some shop so you can do it so
this is the differences it's not that
you can't I mean it's not that you can
do it it's something they've shot you
can't do in c-sharp and vice versa I
mean honestly theory they're equivalent
but in practice it's you know you tend
to do things in a certain way because
the language makes it easy the language
c-sharp does not make it easy to do this
kind of functional programming stuff and
in F sharp makes it easy okay here's
another one prioritize all the things so
here is a function that prints the
numbers one to ten all right this is a
show up code and the first thing we do
if we're inexperienced programs so you
know why have you hard-coded ten why
don't if you want to print one to eleven
or two to seventeen you don't have codes
the numbers pass the numbers in as a
parameter right and then so it's second
nature to us to prioritize this kind of
stuff don't hard-code something when you
can pass it in as a parameter like
second nature now if you have functional
programmer you say well you've
hard-coded the behavior as well it's
like well weapons if I don't want to
print it what happens if I want to you
know do something else of it I don't
hard-code the behavior parameterizing so
a functional programmer would
parameterize the action that you take as
well you just make another parameter and
this is what you do with each thing in
the list and now what we've made is we
actually made a much more generic
designed because we've decoupled the
action the lists are the action and the
looping they're all now to put you
suffer so we actually got a more
decoupled design fact this is no longer
just printing the list it could be doing
anything within us this iterating over
this and doing something
it's easy in F sharp because you can
just stick the proud to right there it's
really easy to do you just type it and
you don't have to worry about what type
it is I'd what is the type of action I
don't know the compiler will flip around
for me
so it's very easy to do which is why
people do it again it's just a natural
behavior and they're sharp to do this
kind of thing let's look at a more
complex example let's look at them say
that we have a product and a thumb and
obviously there's some duplicate code
here and don't repeat yourself right so
what can we do to not repeat ourselves
so what we're going to do is we want to
notice that some of the code is common
the looping through the list is common
code that the initial value is different
and the action that we take each time
through the loop is different right so
we have some stuff which is in common
and some stuff which are different so
what we naturally do is you parameterize
the stuff that's different and keep the
common code the same so here's how to
look at F sharp the function that does
it is called fold we have some
parameters we have the action parameter
and the initial value parameter and then
the list of things so we're going to say
the total so far is the initial and
initialize it to the initial value I'm
going to be using mutable here just to
make it look like the C sharp there are
other ways of doing it now sharp but
just to make it look the same if each
item the lists we're going to run the
action on the total so far and the new
item in the listen that's going to give
us another total and at the end after
we've gone through every item we have
the final total and that becomes the
return value so there you can see that
we've got the common codes we've got the
initial value in for the prime time
action so this is how you'd write that
code in in F sharp and once you've done
that you can go back and you can write
the product and the sum in this way
using this list fold section and there's
the initial value and there's the action
what's cool about doing this way is that
we've got a lot more focus now on what's
the difference in the original c-sharp
code you know a lot of the code was the
common code and it's hard to see what
was special about each case by making it
parameterised is very clear what the
difference in the initial value is and
it's also very
clear what the difference in the action
huge sleepers and the actual loop logic
is you know something we don't care
about if you're doing link this is the
same as a link aggregate this stop fold
is the same as a link aggregate and in
their shot there's lots and lots of
tection functions like this and one of
the challenges when you're learning f
sharp is to memorize what all these
functions are cuz it's like 100 of them
and they're all slightly different
definitely worth spending some time
figuring out what they will do alright
so there's a lot of topics talked about
functional design patterns
I have he'll talk about functional
design patterns if you go to my website
FP patterns or just google for
functional design patterns and I think
you'll come across the talk alright
another thing about F sharp is this
algebraic type system so f sharp types
are different from classes okay a type
is not a class a type is more like this
set and it's something very important to
kind of get into your heads so what is a
type so if we have these functions
there's a set of inputs in there set of
outputs right so a type is just the name
that you give to a set of things there
can be users input so you have all these
integers we're going to give it a name
we're going to call it an integer that's
the name of the set all these strings
were going to give it a name we call its
string so the string type is just a list
of every possible string in the world
right if you have a person type it so
it's just a set of all the possible
people in the world if you have a food
type this is over all possible fruit in
the world all right since it's just a
set it can be anything so you can have a
set of functions so this is the set of
all functions that work on fruits so
this is each of these functions it has a
fruit input and a flute output so it's a
fruit - fruit function this is the set
of all fruit - fruit functions so we
call that the fruit - fruit type so
anything can be anything of your type
now because the types are just data
because it's just a set
there's no behavior it's really easy to
glue them together and you can use
composition just like you can for
functions and that's why it's called an
algebraic items because just like an
algebra you can add things and multiply
things in the F chart type system you
can add types and not
types so again we're going to use the
Lego analogy now there's two ways of
gluing types together in a shop you can
end them and even or them okay and I'll
explain what that means in a second so
that's basically two different things so
the end what does it mean to and so
let's say you have fruit salad and a
fruit salad is one each of an apple and
a banana and a cherry okay now that is
the common this kind of anding together
a name is a first name and a last name
and address is a street and a city and a
postcode riddle this is what you used to
in all languages have a data structure
like this okay and an f-sharp could
write like this okay so a fruit salad as
well as an Apple property and a banana
property in a cherry popped all right
that's something you're very familiar
with the other way is something that you
probably won't be familiar with if
unless you've had experience with
functional languages often you will have
a choice of things as snack is a apple
or banana or a cherry it's a choice one
of these things not all of them but one
of them only and this is the kind of
type that's not available in c-sharp and
in extra up is called a discriminated
Union type or a some type and this case
you use the vertical bar so this is an
apple or it's a banana or it's a cherry
okay these are really really useful
types one of the things I miss in C shop
that's in their shop is like even forget
about the functional program side this
is fantastic and I will see why in a
minute so let's look at an example of
how you might do this so let's say you
have a business requirement that you're
going to accept card payment payments
for an e-commerce and you can all right
you know you can accept cash you can
accept a check or you can scepter credit
card all right so if there's cash
there's no other information if there's
a check you need a check number if it's
a credit card you need a credit card
type and a card number and so on so how
would you implement this these
requirements well if you you know
c-sharp programmer you'd probably say
well okay I'm going to start with some
sort of base class or some interface or
something and then I'm going to create a
cash class that inherits from an
al-qaeda check class with some extra
data then hits
and I'll create a card class with Mexico
later than house from and so on so
that's probably the some of the object
oriented we're using inheritance now
that's fine except that you can out four
different files probably because you
wouldn't put them all in the same file
it's kind of contends a little bit ugly
let's look at how f-sharp is very
different so in F sharp you build the
system by composing smaller types so
we're starting for some simple primitive
types are going to say a check number is
an int and a card numbers of string so
those are just primitives and then we're
going to say that a card type is a Visa
or a MasterCard that's an all type a
choice type and then we're going to say
a credit card is a card type and card
number and that multiplication that's
the pair that's the F sharp symbol for
tuple as a pair of those things and now
our payment method is a choice it's
either cash or it's a cheque or it's a
card and if it's a cheque there's some
extra information and if there's a card
there's some extra information and then
we'll say okay the payment amount is
another primitive type and then the
currency is a choice between euros and
dollars and then finally our top level
payment is going to be an amount plus of
currency class or method so there's an
end so what we've done here is we've
built a complex type in 20 lines of
codes without writing any real coach
this is a great way of doing kind of
design okay you can get this good
there's on one piece of paper is really
nice so you can see it's a very
different way of thinking about how you
construct your domain model so this is
one of the principles in F sharp used
types as kind of executable
documentation so if I showed you this
this is f sharp code can you guess what
domain this is I just by looking at the
code even if you want an F sharp expert
can you guess what this is I think you
can even say well it's something to do
with playing cards right and you can see
that the suit there's a choice between a
club and a diamond in the heart and
whatever card is a pair a suit in a rank
and a hand as a mister cards and deckers
mister cards and a player as a name and
and so I'm settled those are the nouns
you can also document verbs so think to
deal is a function and you start off
with the deck that's your input the
output is a new deck because the decks
immutable so now I'm going to have a
deck with missing a card and you're also
going to have a card on the table so
that's the output similarly when you
pick up a card off the table the input
is the is your hand plus the card on the
table that's the input and the output
you have a new hand and the card on
tables now disappears because
everything's immutable so you've got a
different hand it's not you haven't
mutated your hand you have a different
hand with this extra card in it it fits
on one screen so it's documentation it's
also code this is compatible code is
very nice here's another example of
executable presentation if I show you
this and I say what payment methods are
accepted it's like really obvious right
now with the arrow thing I've have to
look in four different files I'd have to
find all the things that inherit it's
not really obvious just by looking at
the code what payment methods are
accepted I have to look at some
documentation probably so I think this
is really nice if you're trying to do
like domain design something so another
big topic I don't really have enough
time I have a whole talk on domain
garden design and designing the types
and I am doing that talk this afternoon
I also have a book coming out soon it's
an early access right now it should be
out in a couple of months so there's
basically this topic like interactivity
the last thing and I've got a few
minutes left before I forget I just want
to say that don't forget if you're
interested in F sharp or any other
function language there is a lab where
anyone can show up and you can ask
questions of the functional tract people
so the functional prac I think is in
this room all day and all tomorrow and
you know if you're interested in
programming just stay in this room and
if you've got questions like they come
to the functional lab and you can ask
questions of people and we can do curve
demos and stuff and there's something
else I was going to say
right interactivity so I've got a few
minutes left
and let me just show you some enter to
by the way f-sharp fun is a few words in
this job I just want to point that out
I'm not trying to imply anything just
purely purely by coincidence
one thing about if I think it is a fun
language I mean I don't think anyone
says I love programming so job is
fantastic your jelly no Java I think the
thing about Franklin language is because
it's concise it feels like a scripting
language so you feel like you can select
type stuff and it kind of works which is
very nice so I am going to switch to
visual studio if you can see that okay
yeah so let me show you some code so
here's a here's some real F sharp code
so this is in F sharp you have the this
is f sharp scripts but next shot you can
actually like highlight codes and you
can run it interactively I'm going to
say execute in interactive now what
happens is it pops up down here at the
bottom modem if you can see that so
basically it's one this piece of code
just this one snippet of code and I can
so I can interactively play with this
pen well that's interesting no wonder
what happens there and I can say you
know add one to five and it's like it
doesn't have to compile I can just like
one it's both enter in that six so
that's very nice so here's a here's a
classic thing think of a number this is
a game think of a number add 1 to it
square it subtract 1 divided by than we
first thought of subtract the number you
first thought of and the answer is 2
okay so this is kind of a children's
thing now an F sharp this is how you'd
write it you see if you add one square
it subtract one divided by the number
you first thought of subtract by normal
you first of all Tov okay there's our
functions and then we just pipe them so
you start with a number you've first
thought of you pipe it into add 1 you
pipe it into square it you can pipe that
into know so this code looks very much
like the requirements this Python model
is great for this kind of thing a jig it
kind of looks like your codes and what I
can do is then like run it and see
and I highlight everything and there it
is
notice that I didn't specify what kind
of function it was its figured out that
you pass the integer and it returns an
integer it's nice if we think of a
number if I pass in ten
hey the answer is two if I pass in
eleven the answers - and you know it
because it's so easy and let's see log
it and then I'm going to turn so here
I'm going to use a semicolon - what's
the problem oh I need to pass the X in
there all right and then answer this is
how easy you can like I want you know it
didn't tell me what the region number
was so I'm going to do this I'm just
going to stick it in the pipeline and
that mutineer helper function that logs
the input as that so I can play with it
interactively and go down here highlight
it all again and try it again
and now this time it says a is because
I've got a bug in my code because I
didn't say this an integer there we go
so the nice thing about interacting I
didn't have to write a unit test I could
like play with it and find a bug all
right so by playing with I already found
a bug and it's like it took me seconds
to fix it so this feels like doing
Python or JavaScript doesn't even like
JavaScript but certainly feels like
Python to me
very nice very easy to work with I'll do
one more quickly and I got about a
minute left so this is a Roman digit
converter so I'm going to define a type
Roman digit so I'm going to use a choice
and I'm going to say okay a Roman number
is a list of digits and to convert a
digit to an internal and say well if
it's an AI that's a one over severe to
five and so on and then I'm just going
to not going to really go through the
code but I'm just showing that you think
this is what their shots that looks like
I'm going to map it and then one of
summits so here's my digits and
the answer 16 if I change the digits to
be XX then the answer is now 26 and I
put another one in here and it's now 27
so you can see it's really easy to play
around with this is one of the legacies
but it's a fun language to work with
right so that's the demo likes it feels
next ripping owns a lot of fun to work
with and that is it thanks very much the
slides and the video will be up on my
website in a couple of weeks under C
sharp if you want F sharp insulting we
have a consultant communication works
most importantly if you want to know
more about F sharp F sharp org is the
workplace should go so thanks very much
and don't forget to fill in the thing
when you go out thanks so much